is that creativity well it's creativity
if it's not acting within the scheme
that we had
[Music]
previously so we'll start with the
question of is whether the universe is
purely
material or our imagination and
creativity beyond the laws of the
physical world so Roger perhaps you
could start by helping us with this word
material and how to understand it I hope
I can but I'm afraid it might I might
just confuse people the trouble is since
quantum mechanics when I say that I mean
the
physics which in the 20th century was
developed uh starting with Max Plank and
people like Einstein got very much
involved but there you think of things
which you might consider as particles
and they behave like waves so is this
distinction between what you think of as
particle like or stuff material in some
sense or just wavy things Wess or
something and the trouble is that
according to Quantum Mechanics
everything which behaves like particles
at one level will behave like waves at
another and when I say at level it's
really a question of when you're talking
about a fre frequency very high
frequencies things behave more like
particles and very low frequencies they
behave like waves now is this
distinction sort of removed now seems to
me it's it's not the kind of Distinction
physicists like to make um you might
think of well electromag the light light
you see electromagnetic waves at one
level these are photons these are
individual particles and depending on
what kind of experiment you're talking
about you might consider them as a sort
of wav likee entities in some field
which is not intrinsically particle like
in one's imagination at least or things
which um well I mean any anything which
behaves at a particle high frequencies
will behave like a wave at low
frequencies it's not always we know how
to do this for example with gravity you
do have things like called gravitational
waves but nobody has ever noticed the
particulate nature of gravity which
should in principle be there but that
depends on combining Einstein's general
relativity with quantum mechanics in
ways which um haven't been achieved at
least I don't think they' been
achieved yes um very interesting um of
course Roger and
um first one want say that there were so
many meanings to the word
material um and we were talking about
this earlier and Roger was saying it's
not really a word that scientists would
now use um because of our knowledge of
the nature of what we used to call
particles and
Fields but one important way in
philosophy is to somehow designate
lumpen matter that has nothing to do
with Consciousness it is simply
objective and there and if you are such
a
materialist I say you're not somebody
who overvalues matter but somebody who
undervalues matter because according to
your theory if you leave matter alone
for a few Million Years it'll start
producing B on passion which is a very
extraordinary thing for that lamp of
matter to do so you're forced to accept
that matter and Consciousness are not
entirely distinct and I'm sure there are
people probably including Roger who
disagree with this but fortunately there
are very very many physicists who do say
that we cannot consider matter apart
from Consciousness
entirely but I I take the position that
matter is something that we've never
directly experienced there are aspects
of experience that that we call material
that's as close as we get we experience
Consciousness directly we know
Consciousness through Consciousness but
we know matter only through our
Consciousness as an aspect of it and I
take the view that matter is a a form or
phase of Consciousness that offers a
certain degree of permanence and a
certain degree of resistance for a while
and permanence and resistance are very
important in creativity extremely
important balancing um flow with
permanence and um balancing um the the
sort of um the force that pushes in a
certain direction with something that
actually resists it it's out of that
resistance often that things come as the
colors of light come out of a prism
um that splits the single light that
those are the sort of thoughts I I have
about it but I would say that nowadays
very few people are reductive
materialist in this oldfashioned way
physics is against it experience is
against it and reason is against it
people like Einstein and shinger and der
were a bit more polite than I am they
say the theory is incomplete I'm saying
the theory is actually self inconsistent
so I'm a bit Ruder than they were but it
needs something to be done and that's
where a bit of
creativity absolutely is necessary it's
a very thrilling illustration of
openness and creativity within science
but I want to come to you in a moment es
but I think Ian you wanted to come back
on that well yes I mean obviously
um I'm I'm just a a child in relation to
to Roger on on physics but enough people
in physics would take a different
position that Consciousness does
actually affect what we
perceive and um I think the the trouble
is that talking about an inconsistency
or a paradox um is not necessary neily a
sign that we're getting it wrong it may
be that we need to expand the way in
which we think about our knowledge um
here I can't forbear mentioning
something that I'm well known for the
differences between the attention paid
by the right and the left hemisphere and
the left hemisphere values above all and
sees fixity
certainty um the the known and familiar
um and Brooks no uh possibility of
complexity of an implicit nature whereas
the right hemisphere sees that what is
is complexly interrelated interacting
and that there is no ultimately no
certainty there is no uh sort of
perfection as it were that is the real
truth that it is a journey and I think
that's a very important idea philosophy
is a process and science is a process
and I believe reality is in process go
on in no could I just ask Roger I mean
um my understanding such as as it is of
quantum field theory is that this in
some ways spans this problem of
resolving Einstein's theory of
relativity with quantum mechanics and I
think we have to make a point clear here
this is special relativity you see
Quantum field Theory certainly arose
from making quantum mechanics broaden it
into a theory which is consistent with
the special Theory special yes so it's
not talking about gravity no so it's a
different story I mean sure it's
important to get it consistent with
special I think there are problems with
Quantum F Theory you keep running into
Infinities and things like this and and
there are all sorts of ways that the
people in the area deal with them shovel
them in under the carpet one way or
another and I I don't like that myself I
think I'd like a theory where you don't
have to um sort of rub your Infinities
out if the number gets so big then you
can ignore it that seems to be the point
of view that's what happens when you
follow the quantum field Theory idea
because it's it's certainly trying to
bring special relative when I said I
should mention that is the theory of
relativity in where you don't talk about
gravitational fields so special
relativity is to do with how things
behave under motion yes but sort of
uniform motion and you're not thinking
about this what keeps us in our seats
here no no no so it's a different
subject but general relativity which was
Einstein's huge incredible I I consider
uh it came basically out of the blue I
think if you want creativity aample it
special relativity was more or L forced
on people and to make that consistent
with quantum theory and make Quantum
field Theory and as he was saying the
ideas of quantum field Theory arose out
of that Union Yes Yes quite the general
theory of relativity is a different
story do you would you accept David Tong
you know he's for those who don't know
he's a professor of physics at Cambridge
his view that ultimately there is no
discontinuity that discontinuity is an
emergent arising out of
continuity I think that's a very
important Point actually myself but when
you say discontinuity are we talking
about the collapse of the wave function
because that's you can do yes because
that is one of them but but what what I
would want to say about that is that and
I think I'm not entirely out of touch
with with some of the last Century's
physicists that these are different ways
of the same phenomenon existing
exhibiting itself it is a way W but also
it can be quantized
for under certain circumstances but that
quantization is not the ground of it the
ground is its Contin its flow its state
as a wave and the other um certainly
debru would have would have said this
that the the discontinuities arise out
of that and on top of that but hooray
for approximation and hoay for you know
things that don't completely fit because
these are the things that strive make a
strive for further illuminations in
which we might have to accept that there
is no final certainty or Precision to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit I a.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas